welcome to USMLE preparation playlist
in this playlist we'll talk about
Concepts which are high yield and short
it would be very useful and informative
for your preparation in this installment
we'll talk about T-cell activation
T-cell activation requires antigen
presenting cells like dendritic cells
which can encounter pathogen and engulf
them
after engulfing the pathogen dendritic
cell displays fragments of these
pathogen or antigens on Class 2 MHC
molecules eventually dendritic cells are
motile so they would move to the nearby
lymph node where they can interact with
CD4 positive T helper cells and they
display their antigen on a Class 2 MHC
molecule
eventually it leads to activation of the
T helper cell let us look at how T-cell
activation take place there are three
important signals that triggers T-cell
activation the first signal is MHC Class
2 and interaction with the T Cell
receptor that give rise to the signal 1
for Activation the second signal comes
from the interaction between
cd8086 and cd28 present in the T Cell so
this gives rise to signal 2 and the
signal 3 comes from cytokines such as
interleukin 2 interleukin 2 binds to
specific interleukin receptors and give
rise to the signal 3 for Activation thus
a combination of three signals lead to
the activation of T cells once the T
cells are activated they entered the
cell cycle they proliferate and
eventually they would be differentiating
into different T helper cell subgroups
such as th1 th2 th17 or let's say memory
T cells
if you want detailed video you can
always click on the I button or
description for more details get more
notes and flashcards in my Facebook and
Instagram page
feel free to support our Channel using
paytm PayPal or UPI see you in next
video